OK, we have to talk.
We have to talk about the situation in Kenosha,
Wisconsin, where 17 year old Kyle Rittenhouse
has now been arrested for murder after shooting
people in what is sort of an amalgam of the
worst of the worst of American culture.
Gun culture, reactionary culture, a police
sort of.
I'm not actually I'm not talking about police,
but I'm talking about people like.
The shooter, who sort of idolize and DFI put
police like figures and want to be out there
with firearms affecting what they believed
to be some kind of militia or gatekeeping,
I don't even know what to call it.
But where I want to start is that what is
very clearly, colloquially speaking, murder.
It will be up to the legal system to determine
if it is legally legal murder.
Right.
Guilt of of murder.
But what is what is, colloquially speaking,
murder?
We are starting to see right wing media implicitly
or explicitly defend the actions of 17 year
old Kyle Rittenhouse.
And I want to start with a clip from last
night's Tucker Carlson program on FOX News.
Take a look at this.
Joy really surprised that looting and arson
accelerated to murder.
How shocked are we that 17 year olds with
rifles decided they had to maintain order
when no one else would?
Everyone could see what was happening in Kenosha.
It was getting crazier by the hour.
So the argument that's being made to sort
of indirectly defend the actions of this kid
are that, listen, if you have chaos in the
streets and nobody else deals with it, then
it's natural that a 17 year old gun toter
is going to start policing the streets, even
if you grant, which I don't, that there is
some problem at the country level of the streets
being out of control.
Remember, overall crime has been on the decline
for a long time in the United States, even
if you were to grant that, which I don't.
The idea that it's natural for gun toting
17 year olds to be the ones policing the streets
is absolute and complete lunacy.
Now, coverage of this event, if you compare
it to other events, has been unfortunately
the worst of the worst that we could get from
right wing media and even from so-called independent,
not independent media, from so-called nonpartisan
media.
Remember, for example, that the Jacob Blake
story was widely reported on just a couple
of days prior.
And if you look at, for example, two New York
Post tweets, which we are putting up on the
screen for you on the left, The New York Post
tweeting about Jacob Blake, who was killed
by police.
Jacob Blake had a knife in his car when he
was shot by police on the right, the same
New York Post with a picture of Kyle written
house cleaning graffiti tweets.
Suspected teen gunman Kyle Rittenhouse spotted
cleaning Kenosha graffiti before the shooting.
Now, no mention of the fact that in Wisconsin,
the minimum age to open carry is 18.
So shooting aside, what Kyle Rittenhouse was
doing was against the law.
But, of course, I guess nobody stopped him
to say, hey, what state are you from and what
age are you?
And is it even legal for you to be here with
this gun?
Remember that when Trayvon Martin was killed
by George Zimmerman, he was 17 years old.
Corporate media, of course, the right was
very quick to immediately say he was 17.
But this this guy was an adult.
He was big, aggressive guy.
And he's really an adult than he should have.
He should be considered one in his interaction
with George Zimmerman.
And yet here you have a gun toting 17 year
old white kid, also 17, like Trayvon Martin.
But this one's a kid who was cleaning graffiti.
And any way, like Tucker Carlson says, if
the streets are out of control, isn't it natural
for gun toting 17 year olds to be out there
policing?
This is crazy.
This is crazy now.
We have now retrospectively found out that
this kid, Kyle Rittenhouse.
I, I maybe shouldn't even be saying this kid.
He's 17.
And, you know, the legal system will determine
how he should be.
He should be dealt with about two hours before
the first shooting.
He was actually interviewed.
Rittenhouse was at a Kenosha vehicle dealership
by some guy who was live streaming.
What was going on in Kenosha?
Take a look at this.
Protect it from the citizens.
And I just got pepper spray by person in the
crowd.
Non-lethal.
We don't have non-lethal ready to defend the
properties.
Yes, we are.
Now, I can ask, can you guys step back?
Medical.
And then we had another interview with Kyle
Rittenhouse, who spoke to Richie McGinnis,
who's a video editor at The Daily Caller,
a right wing news and opinion site.
And again, just stumbling across this gun
toting 17 year old.
Take a look.
You're doing out here, obviously, you're armed
and you're in front of this business.
We saw burning last night.
So it's a.
So people are getting injured.
Our job is to protect this part of my job.
Somebody's hurt.
I'm running into harm's way.
That's why I'm here right now.
I think that there's a few different things.
There's a bunch of stories here.
One story, as I've already pointed out, is
the immediate media narratives that are created.
White kid with the gun.
It's just a kid.
It's natural that he was out there.
He's a good kid.
He was cleaning graffiti, et cetera.
Even Jacob Blache immediately.
Oh, well, there was a knife in his car.
Did was that.
Did police know that at the time?
There's no claims about.
Well, there was a there was a phone call the
police may have suspected, etc., but the handling
of these two is completely different.
And that's one storyline.
The other storyline is this broader narrative.
Aside from this particular case, it's the
broader narrative of Republicans for months
now have been harping on the streets are out
of control.
Joe Biden wants to defund the police, which
he doesn't.
Everything is going to go completely haywire
if Joe Biden is elected.
We need the Second Amendment and Joe Biden
wants to take it away.
And then after all of that, this kid goes
out and he actually sort of does what would
naturally follow.
Remember the concept of stochastic terrorism
for months and months of Republicans and Trump
and the RNC pushing this exact story.
Now, the truth is that very few of the deaths
linked to protests have been a result of violence
by protesters.
That's really, really important to understand,
because the rhetoric from Trump and the conservative
movement has been painting the picture that
protesters protesting against police brutality
have gone out there and attacked people and
killed people, et cetera.
The reality is that some of these violent
events have been linked to movements like
the Boogaloo movement, which is a right wing
movement that wants to generate a second civil
war.
If you look at reviews of the different deaths
that have been linked to protests, many of
them are either unrelated or unclear if they
are related.
Mike, Juan Blanchard was shot on May thirty,
first in Riverside, Illinois, by an unknown
assailant in an incident apparently unrelated
to protests.
But it's wrapped in as part of the protest
violence.
David McCarty shot on June 1st in Louisville.
McCarty ran a barbecue store, was shot and
killed by members of the National Guard when
he apparently fired at them with a handgun.
The David Dorn's situation from June 2nd in
St. Louis, Dawn, is this retired police officer
allegedly shot and killed by Stefan Cannon.
As Dawn was responding to it a lot.
An alarm at a friend's business in an area
where looting was reportedly happening again.
It's not the protesters that are out there
doing even a lot of the violence that is reported
on.
So what's dangerous about this is that when
you combine this with the rhetoric from the
RNC and from Trump and the imagery and claims
that Joe Biden is going to let crime run rampant.
Defund the police, which he doesn't want to
do.
So on and so forth.
What else do you expect?
So Kyle Rittenhouse has personal responsibility
here.
The legal system is going to adjudicate that
for sure.
And yet we also can't ignore without absolving
any him of any responsibility.
The environment in which this is all being
ginned up.
And we have to think about what this is going
to look like on November 4th if Donald Trump
loses by a small margin.
And that is a real concern, which I'm going
to talk about tomorrow.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
We'll have more coverage of this upcoming